[Music]
Hey hello everyone how's it going good
but what about party yesterday did you
stay long nice that's a good feeling
I was about to stay long enough for us
like now maybe I need to work on my
slide a bit more and maybe I should have
stayed longer so you'll see okay so as
you have seen you know this title of my
talk is about tensorflow and I kind of
like had a bit of like hard time to see
how deep we are in a topic so if you can
put your hands up how many of you do
some machine learning like I don't know
from time to them whoa that's amazing
okay how many of you did some narrow
networks nice and deep learning cool and
tensorflow I like your people okay so
since you know depending on the city
sometimes background is like a bit
harder right for instance in Munich I
also organize machine learning meetup
when we have like a bunch of talks about
I don't know all kind of a deep learning
right and you know sometimes you know
that the city is like a bit more
prepared so like general audience is
like a bit aware of things here I wanted
to kind of start with the small things
and doctor go like deeper and more high
level so hopefully even if you I don't
Android developer or like web developer
you're not going to be feeling lost it's
more like you will get there so we will
start slowly and after I get somewhere
else as you also noticed the slice
didn't look like super amazing like for
instance like features like super small
you know why because it's in Jupiter and
there is a real jazz at rendering that
that also means that all the codes that
are going to be showing today and
they're going to be a bunch of food you
can just download Jupiter notebook and
just like run through it so
it's kind of excuse for myself like why
it doesn't look that amazing yes I mean
one of the parts as well that you know
people start talking like all this
machine learning stuff right and it's
all amazing right Google changed from
mobile first way I first like and
sometimes it feels like hi pipe right
and I didn't want to bring like many
examples like how you can do like image
classification is in this part so since
we are talking about Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy
I brought this like rebel fish like who
is aware what is that yes at least a
couple of people travel the galaxy so in
the original movie right they had this
small pebble fish right that one of the
extras kind of like putting inside of
the ear right and this fish is
translating to no matter what language
you are listening to right into your own
language basic right so it sounds pretty
cool right you don't need to learn a
language you can go to whatever country
and it just like does it for you turns
out it's not like you know futuristic
and super crazy if you have seen you
know announcement event from Google I
don't maybe a couple of weeks ago they
also announced like Google pixel bars
right so those like headphones that you
can tap on them and they're going to be
doing translation right and it's kind of
like pretty close what Babel Fish
basically does right but you can
basically buy it more or less right now
and it's already going to be working
what is interesting about that that I
don't know I think like a huge
percentage of that is basically based on
the machine learning and deep learning
rate on this case on this picture you
can see just like a nice animation how
Google does a bunch of learning right so
they do like corporates they have a
corpus like of different languages right
and essentially they are able to you
know like a build embeddings that means
that you know you can he didn't have
different words right and based like how
words are used right there is some
common sense what they called
distributed presentations right and
based on this information if you give
you a network like a huge amount of text
right you can learn that I don't stage
is somehow similar to a speaker right or
close in the embedding space and
what they also using like for
translation like it's a part of it right
another hand like right now even you
know generating this audio waves is also
in many cases like way better if you use
like deep learning there it was like an
article from Apple and this one from
deep mind and they basically swish it
more or less completely right and sounds
of you know what Google home saying what
is as a part of Google saying and most
likely this Google Buzz say sounds also
like way better like way realistic right
because you didn't do concatenation of
like smaller pieces but the network does
is like NPN basically it's a wave net
yes and you know when you starting to
talk about all those I know like machine
learning and deep learning stuff usually
you see this picture like how many of
you have seen that yeah it's quite many
especially at Google i/o another place
and you know I mean it's cool like it
showing you some informations there are
some layers right and I don't like kind
of a structure right and it's magically
kind of works right but it's a problem
right is that sometimes it's kind of
like missing all the details right
you're like okay I got data I put it
inside pom-pom and it already works
right it always reminds me of this like
oh how do you do that you do circles
pom-pom and here we go like here's
already oh and what is even more funny
and like the same time it's like helpful
right that many people that I was like
meeting like lately right they were like
so what do you do I do some data science
machine learning is they're like oh yeah
I can do data science and machine
learning like I eat the course like on
Udacity you put data inside bumbum and
it already works right and I mean on one
hand it's fine right because people feel
motivated another hand like it's not
that easy right otherwise we're not
gonna be get paid for that and I wanted
to go like a bit more in details right
but is it gonna be like all this crazy
about formulas and whether it is a
formula because it was for against right
how you can do that
no like I think it's it doesn't make
sense right because I mean we don't have
like time for that and maybe you know in
it like more your own time to digest it
and like
good about that so we kind of like how
like a different approach we kind of go
through a bunch of like code samples
trying to you know like show some pain
points and from there explain okay why
did we do that or like what was
happening there yeah and some first part
is basically it's just how we do kind of
logistic regression just to give you a
feeling like what is that about and
after you'll you know go like deeper a
bit yes if any moment you feel like was
happening just put your hands up and I
will react on that and I don't know
we will slow down maybe do something
crazy okay so I think if you were doing
I don't know computer science or other
related subjects most likely you have
heard about logistic regression right
and you know already how is it working
and like have some ideas it's a very
basic and super simplified approach that
you have some nice Keaton right because
everybody loves them and you have some
you know vectors that you transfer it
afterwards right and theoretically you
can you know learn some kind of like
representation that will be able to you
know have some activations or like hot
points like on the pictures that will
say okay because I'm getting you know
positive values here right and negative
like somewhere else right I can
basically protect that it looks like
cats like in that direction right and
because we just wanted to do it super
simple we can also add some
non-linearity right that in future we
can use it for something more
complicated right and I mean there's
like a bunch of formulas how you can you
know in terms of like mathematics define
a drive and yeah so you can define your
functions that is based on your ways
right your input vector as umpires you
can add some activation on top of it and
you can have some loss function right so
you can understand how bad you are right
and on top of it you can have like a
cost function that you're trying to
minimize right next one yeah but you
know if you have this
party still need to learn like what
weights are coming from right and I'm
not really going like that much deep in
details because I think it might be like
a good topic to talk about but you can
also like easily Google how exactly
backpropagation works but ideas that you
know you have the way how you compute
your cost function right and you can
understand how to take like derivative
of that so you know okay what smaller
pieces you are taking from there and if
you have like a small implementation in
I don't know like a numpy for instance
it's not going to be like super
complicated right in that direction so
the foremost that you have seen before
like it just goes like in the
presentation of an umpire right and once
you are analytically compute like
derivatives you can also like measure
how much they come in from right and
when you do like in direction of
optimization right what you do is
basically you compute your gradients
right you know that okay you have some
learning rate how much we kind of like
going deeper and like how fast we are
but overall is about you know step by
step trying to adjust like your ways and
they're like biases in the direction and
I mean okay it's not that hard right you
can also you got this working you got
like your weights and after you
basically confuse the same functions
that you had even before right and yeah
sounds good in that direction right and
I mean I'm not focusing that much on
those files because they still going to
be like available online and I better
spend it with my time like this tensor
flow it's just like to show you how that
you know it's not like totally crazy
yeah and essentially your model is
basically what it does like it
initializes those like ways and biases
right you do some optimization steps
that you show before and when it's a get
like into proximity or for your good
parameters you say like okay we get from
there you know it's kind of like take it
some time and depending like on
structure because we could just was just
a progression right it's pretty
straightforward but if you go to like a
deeper like I don't know you could do
like multi-layer perceptrons even it's
getting more complicated because you
still need to
do some Guardian checking like other
techniques that help you to understand
that your implementation is still
working right and I mean especially
right now there is like a bunch of
companies that do all those like a
frameworks for neural networks and I
mean sometimes think about feelings that
um you know everybody wants to invent
their own right there's like Amazon's
there's Google there's Facebook risk
afraid to and stuff like that but today
we're going to be talking more about
tensorflow right so tensorflow is kind
of like a big animal right it has many
things that not really super visible for
us like for instance all the super
useful but not super you know applicable
by like the percentage of people is
execution engine reg that knows like
okay how do I work like with your
symbolic graphs like how do i schedule
them how well like what to do is there
right and plus some like optimizations
as well that can run your vector
operations like even faster on all kind
of hardware right so you don't need to
think like okay I implemented like a
numpy now I need to use like sink it's
called like size-wise there's a Python
package that you can not like cipher but
coupe I so it can run it like when I
could architecture but in this case
tensorflow is kind of like taking care
of all those things and even if it's
like TPU you don't need to like you know
the implements the stuff like on your
own on top of it there's like a front
end right like said it gives you ability
to write some Python stuff and even top
of whizzers also like layers that give
some you know a structures that you need
to re-implement it lightly they also
release like data sets that help you to
you know like since you already have
GPUs right for like fast learning but in
many cases like pre-processing the data
is like getting like a bottleneck and
say trying to build like a good rapper
on that to make it even faster and on
top of it there is like a chaos that is
also going to cover in the talks that
gives like even higher level of
abstractions there and what is kind of
relatively new is like Kent estimators
if you use s Killearn kit or circuit
learn
it's kind of in a very similar format
you can just create like DNN and say
feet and it's like kind of magically
works so theoretically you can also use
that but practically it feels like more
that you know you're working on that if
you're like defining something like
customize and architecture wise is also
more helpful if you give like a bit of
concepts introduction right so there is
like tensorflow as a word right like to
cast like two different parts like one
is like dance fur and another one is
flow right but obvious obviously but so
if you're talking about tensors right so
it's like two different like different
pieces right in mathematics there is a
different definition of tensors
but in tensor flow world is basically
you can define you know different ways
of item in this case like constant right
but multiplication is also going to be
like a part of this operation or like in
this case if you print it right first
it's going to be tensor sorry but the
result is also tensor right so you can
define your graph basically in those
like tensors what is also interesting
right that you know if you do like this
multiplication here and we print result
and then of the day it doesn't really
show us a result right like why is it
happening because all the concepts that
you know tensorflow and this like
scheduling enging it does it later so
it's like lazy evaluation and you know
like it's you can do some crazy stuff
like how to optimize it because I mean
for this case there's nothing to
optimize but in general case there is
something more advanced for that if you
have like deep network but what its kind
of essential for that that once you have
tensorflow session right you can say
okay there's a you know this operation
set or tensors is that I would like to
execute right and when you do session
run it's kind of okay there's some
scheduling some magic in the background
and only after it does evaluation and
execution of this lazy formula that you
had right and what you can do is
basically it's kind of like a hacky way
and they're not super visible right now
but wait a second so once you define it
like in the current scope of your script
or Jupiter notebook right you can also
this
chupa turn sorry there's a tensor board
you can try to visualize it and since
since this one is like slightly betting
not really good we have this one that
basically shows that for the operation
that we were showing right it's going to
have the graph like that right and if
you are surprised at this like
multiplication doesn't look very you
know comfortable for you you can still
use like a different sign like depending
like on what kind of multiplication you
have yeah but basically you have a
session session basically based on what
back-end you're using and like have word
to execute those things yes what is kind
of essential for that is also been able
to you know pass some variables so like
in this case we are saying that okay I'm
creating like a placeholder right for X
this yeah some informations are going to
be using afterwards and you can
afterwards pass it inside of your
session so this is how you're also going
to be like learning your models yeah if
we you know a go interaction of
initializing parameters right because
it's what we usually do in the beginning
it's where tensorflow is kind of like
getting your boss right because every
time when you okay I'm defying like a
variable for my ways right and it's not
like how you would do in production
system but it's more like a visible like
what's happening there right and when
you're defining that you will also say
okay like what is the shape of this part
right and in many cases like you need to
okay sit and like understand what you're
going to be doing there but you know
there's like some complexity with this
parts company and I will mention it like
a bit later like why is it important
yeah and there is also like some fancy
way like how you can do like proper
initialization like this like have your
utilization for instance and stuff like
that but what I would like you to just
like see that okay we initializing
parameters and you need to know like
shapes of the layers what you're going
to be using right and when we were
talking about you know there's like a
loss function like and how we only ate
all those things right before we were
like implementing like our own right
and depending like okay is it what kind
of classification is it like multi-label
right you still need to do like your own
jobs alright with that case like you
know because tensorflow is already like
a framework right they already have all
things like in place and it's also kind
of like just going like a bit ahead
sometimes in Cara's you like missing
some parts that it was a coal like or I
can curse it's like a low level but even
for multi-label classification because
of issues that we need to like implement
stuff yeah but back to this part so you
can basically just use cross-entropy
villages and in your code is basically
going to be pretty straightforward right
you're getting I know your labels your
lodges and after you can just pass it
like as a convention yeah so it doesn't
really go like super crazy right we
still you know in original part with
logistic regression we had some forward
propagation and this was basically what
we have here right we have like a
separate you know the part that has like
our parameters right that you want to
pass on like if you do like inside of
the bridge but basically what you do is
pretty similar what you did like an
umpire beforehand right just like it's
different prefix yeah and they already
have like all kind of like activations
like raloo or liquor we'll lose that
kind of like a part of the story for you
yeah if you feel like that you know you
don't really know like what directions
we should be like was it raloo like or
sigmoid or why we're talking about those
things
just like catch me afterwards and you
can tell like a long discussion like how
I know things are helpful like for you
know gradient vanishing like an
explosion like afterwards but I'm afraid
that here in the stage it just like take
it as a given and after you can always
go deeper and see like why I don't know
I'm using real ooh and not like proper
sigmoid here but I wouldn't go like that
much in details yes and after if you you
know like defining kind of the model
like in terms of flow away right besides
like having the bullet plates that we
kind of
do some reshaping part right like a
placeholder like parameters that we
showed before it but essentially it's
pretty similar right you feel like a
forward propagation what you did before
right you were like analytically
computing like your gradient right and
after trying to like implement it
what tensorflow gives you is a hell-like
a set of like optimizers rights that
depending like okay this is going to be
gradient descent or stochastic gradient
descent or the one is momentum right
just like to you know for those of you
who are not familiar is that just
depending like how you you know you have
a function that you're trying to find I
don't know like maximum or minimum
basically what you optimizing for there
is like a different numerical way to do
that and there is like a different here
all those things right so for instance
like Adam might do some adaptive stuff
that this most sophisticated and just
using like stochastic gradient descent
but there's somebody who just want to
play around with that you just can you
know like use like Adam optimizer is
like one of the fourth ones and just get
it from there and what you can do
afterwards is okay you providing like a
learning rate and you can say like
minimize my cost that defined beforehand
right and even if you remember like cost
function was not that complicated to
define right so just like a sigmoid
cross-entropy right now it's like a bit
complicated but after vehicles like
switched into chaos when it's going to
be like way simpler just like to show
you also like a part of complexity yeah
and what you could do afterwards you
he'll your sessions that you're running
right here they kind of like do some
like mini Bosch part but basic ideas
that you he'll like a session that
you're running with your optimizer and
like cost right and yeah essentially it
just if you run this model is going to
be sure and like okay like after every
book and how is your loss is basically
changing so it goes pretty far pretty
good read and again I'm gonna share
Jupiter notebook afterwards so you can
like click those things and try to
change the parameters and
makes them available yes okay so we can
write those things right but one of the
problems why the things was not taking
office like neural networks right I mean
they're like multiple theoretical things
right that we were not able to train
them deep enough right but another
problem resources right I remember like
back in I don't 2007 I believe like in
ooh you're like using some neural
networks for like as a kind of student
project saying for I think like
detecting some faces and like classify
and like other things right
we had like a separate machine that was
running like for quite some days and it
was like training and like on its own
right and you know it was like machine
with CPU right so it's like gonna be
like super slow but the problem is that
as you know human individuals right or
like your personal project hobby one
it's like take some time right to train
these things hopefully for us like
they're like a bunch of cool companies
that invest in like a good amount of
resources that make it available and
they also work in like on building like
a cool architecture so like in this case
is inception model from Google and you
can like download already pre trained
models like you see like okay which they
pretty trained for some cases right but
turns out that if you haven't just like
a deep like deep layers right after
having like a bunch of you know you have
like a bunch of classes right and in
this case I think they use like in some
cases like it's Google net Acronis or
imagenet like data set was like hundred
tons of images Google has their own data
set but basically as a learning you know
to understand like to classify different
classes right and meanwhile network also
learns different representations right
so if before you were coming from
computer vision background and you're
gonna use like sift or surf feature
descriptors right now you can just use
one of those like networks and get
depending like what you know like level
of presentation already for you and you
can do like crazy stuff that I will show
in a second and I mean there are like a
bunch of like a different you know
network architectures and they already
pre trained one of more famous one is
like vgg 16 and it's like also super old
what I want to show like
this graph is basically especially if
you wanna port it like for mobile or
like some low-level hardware and if you
want to I know
optimize for inference you will see that
you know like on one axis you will see
like number of operations so like how
much you know time it takes and also
resources and another one like accuracy
right and it turns out not the most you
know like number of operations are
getting like the highest accuracy right
so sometimes you can pick up like as
Inception v3 is that relatively or like
rest net from Microsoft that like in
terms of operations it's like pretty low
right which in terms of accuracy is
pretty high so just like keep in mind
that you know there is like a good
comparison of those things and I mean 16
is cool but there is like as a free
training at work that you can be using
and there's also like a nice paper on
archive basically that you can read on
those things yes
okay so imagines that Google trains its
network for you right can we make it
easier and like use it for something for
us right so in many cases they sharing
their models like in the brought a
buffer definition and you can just like
load it as as we do like in this case
right so you can define like a drug
definition and you can like a video file
but basically essentially yeah if you
load it again like it's 10 support
visualizations that shows you how
simplify it looks like if you click on
those blocks they actually going to be
extending so it's going to be as
original image inception model but
basically you get this thing is running
right so we got the model right like and
what we can do afterwards is just
basically if you know like you define
your network right usually you will have
a okay just like different layers right
if you familiar with topic there is some
convolution layers that also take it
into account not only value of the point
right but also you know proximity so you
basically having like a bigger high
level features but usually if it's you
know like multiple classes and zones the
day you're gonna use like soft max right
as a like last layer and what's
happening here right that before soft
max you're gonna have some I don't know
fully connected layer just to like
learn some things there and maybe some
pulling like on top of it and what you
can do is basically use this information
like a sufficient descriptor right and
in this case like I'm taking I don't
know I think like one of this intro
pictures actually and passing like
inside and I will get like a vector of I
think like 2048 or something if I'm not
wrong but basically this bunch of digits
here it's going to be like a really good
feature descriptor for you so you can
easily implement you know if you again
like go to tensor board and you show
some I think is this case is like PCA
but you can also do like a Disney it's
just like a way how you can put like a
multi-dimensional data like in three
dimension in this case but basically you
will see that you know images that kind
of look alike right will have like a
similar image vectors right so you can
easily implement image similarity
without I don't know spending much time
so I've been is this like hackathon in
Zurich like months ago right and we had
like one of projects that we wanted to
add like image similarity and it took us
like there was like one girl who was
doing I think like data science at
Yandex and she was like are going to be
using like surf and sift and I was like
okay and meanwhile I will try to use
some feature description from inception
and it was like way faster on my side
because you know like with all this like
OpenCV stuff that takes some time it
didn't really help that much yeah and if
you go like more in production direction
with all this like image similarity
there's a library called light annoy
like very nice name but it's basically
built by Spotify and they do like a
proximate nearest neighbor or yeah like
Cisco I was a call library but the basic
idea is that once you have those you
know feature representations of fuller
images right you can have some
approximate like neighborhoods right and
it's super fast basically to say like
okay I have this image that's like
belong somewhere here right give me like
a neighborhood of images that look look
alike right so you didn't need to do
like some KNN but you can just like
extract it from the index so if you
didn't productions like super cool
project oh those are like a couple of
tricks so if you're going to be uses it
just like
me or I don't like being me I will tell
you that yeah so you know you have seen
that it's getting easier right you don't
need to implement stuff but it's still
pretty verbose right there's like much
things happening fortunately for us yes
it was like this library Kara's right
and they make it even better so they
like wrap up sayings like together and
they also like add some you know a
proper way to like a handle you know the
ways that you need to input things that
you need to implement ends flow on your
own but basically if you're building
like a simple model is as simple as it
is right you have like a layers yes it
like could be convolutions like or max
pooling or whatever else like you can
you know I can tell you afterwards but
basically what you have afterwards you
have a model and you're adding like all
the layers like in-between so you don't
need to think like okay what is a shape
of the layer before like how to connect
them together it's like you're focusing
on like more important parts than just
like singing about shapes so it's pretty
good right and yeah you can also do like
a pretty second learning approach of you
know model feet with like all your data
and it's pretty good
yeah and after if you want to go more in
details you can also do like a model
summary that shows you okay what layers
you are having like number of parameters
if you want to like decrease number of
parameters because you wanna I don't
know move to like smaller device and you
wanna replace some fully connected
layers with convolutions stuff like that
yeah
and if you do like evaluation is
basically also pretty simple afterwards
right what you can do afterwards is also
like saving this stuff so you know like
once you train it you can get it yet in
different format for carers here but
basically yeah it will generate you like
one is like a graph definition and
another one ways basically that you can
easily load afterwards yeah and it's
like a way how you can load stuff and
there was examples that I trained like
on these data set and yeah it was like
at the end of the day if you give like
original image and you can model predict
that gets you like image and you can
reshape to the proper shade
but basically it will show you that okay
it's like force basically class that has
it so it's basically look like for ya
and if it was not simple right you can
make it even simpler so like chaos in
this case they have already like
applications and like in this case it's
deception with three right and from
there you can just define it and you
know like you can say like ways are
coming from image snare Drive and yeah
and you can help like a graph already
like working here right and yeah if you
have the graph and you can load it you
can just use a prediction from there and
just examples that we had to this image
and depending like on you know classes
that imagenet already having it's gonna
be good but what you can do is basically
freeze like entire and your texture
besides as the last layer and it will
like retrain or the entire network
because it can screw up the ways but
only like your part that you know it
using like a feature representations and
like mapping your feature representation
to your own classes you can go like even
as far as using like one-shot learning
as you know like having like very few
images that you can train on top of it
yes and you know it's already given like
a pretty good idea that if you really
want to use it you don't need to you
know like know all the details it's like
a similar direction of you know as I was
saying if you want to drive a car right
you don't need to know how exactly your
engine works right you can just be like
stirring the wheel and like making it
working and it's basically what's
happening with like many deploring
waters right if you know like a couple
of concepts right how you get like image
features right you can always like build
on top of it so it's kind of a legal
game right and one of example is like
image captioning I didn't really bring
the code inside but I can share with you
if you interested but ideas there's that
you also have image right you have like
some convolutional parts that might be
based like or I don't know like one of
our well-known networks right and after
you do some like Iran and bertrise that
can also map the part of the words that
you are saying right and if you have
like once a data set right you can say
okay this image is a data set has some
descriptions that I don't know like this
like fly or brought this life and after
Network you learn addresses it's pretty
good and you can go like that craziest
you know like even combining like more
advanced right you know you get in like
questions that you know goes through
some LS cm right yeah and the after you
have the same like official descriptors
and after if you didn't use like
sequential model but basically
functional approach for carriers you can
just join it to the side same what else
it's more about data that you are having
but your to set is basically staying the
same yeah
and interest of deployment since you
know it was pretty fast and I think like
many of you like what's happening I need
to check Jupiter of Traverse is there is
like many ways to do that right like one
is the way is your own kind of way and
you have you like tensorflow servings
that optimize for you have your model
and can run it like in the background
and it has you can use like Nvidia
docker and some kubernetes that you
already most likely see you and talk
about that but basically you will have
your own way to structure like an GPUs
that shows those things yeah and for
Android people of you and even Android
things of you there is also like a
version of tensorflow right that you can
train on your like a separate cluster
for instance and doctor just saves the
ways but essentially what you would do
is you have like a gradual dependency
right and you will you know basically
define like it's a part like over your
per to buffer model slice right so you
can put it into your resources and oops
yeah you can also define where are you
fitting in so like all those network
architecture it
they have like a specific name thread so
you can say okay read it in direction of
like input right and give me results
like of output right in this case we
didn't really use like a feature
presentation but we use it like an
original classes and yeah and it will
get you pretty much working and yeah in
this case you can run the same one for n
or like a small Android things device
the only things that I'd also didn't
cover here it's like how to optimize it
right because if you in for inference on
mobile phones there is like a bunch of
like other steps it might be doing like
reducing like you know like how many PC
you are storing like pervades right
because sometimes it's like
representation is pretty high sometimes
you can also be more efficient on
archiving those models so you can easily
you know like decrease the weight of the
models that you save in like by factor
of like 28 billion so if you like
interested about this part I ping me on
Twitter like I should have like a slide
from Enoch when I was talking about
doing deployments like for Android but
overall is basically it's pretty
straightforward so what I wanted
basically to say here is you know there
are like many different pieces right you
can go like pretty low level you can go
like pretty high level right but it's
like your own choice right if you want
you can go pretty high level with yours
with some free training models and you
get results like in a matter of hours so
don't be afraid of like trying set and
you can always go deeper right don't be
you know like scared all that okay I
need to do like you know all those like
derivatives like partial derivatives and
know like bunch of mathematics it's not
said much of rocket science like you can
always go on that level but for the
beginning you can just do like clicky
clicky stuff like combining models and
it still looks pretty cool like if it's
really working for you so yeah like
there was lots of pieces kind of missing
and it's like what's pretty fast but I
hope it's kind of like give you like a
road map right and like a guide
basically right of all things as there
and if you have particular questions on
like similar topics just like catch me
up and we can talk about or cool for
cool games like for one mega Peaks and
stuff like that
yeah is that I finished my talk please
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]